o nosso sistema político e econômico foi
criado há centenas de anos por uma
galera pra resolver os sonhos aquela
época
hoje os nossos governos são um retrato
do sistema outra passado
pessoas motivadas processo enferrujados
e sistemas obsoletos
não são só um estereótipo não são
realidade são dura realidade 77 por
cento dos jovens nas universidades
brasileiras estão insatisfeitos com a
política
os outros 23% é um cargo não sabe nem o
que é política
agora imagina você empreendam empreender
um cenário como esse
considerando que 58 por cento dos jovens
das universidades brasileiras querem
empreender
então quando você olha para esse cenário
onde os governos passam por tantas
dificuldades tantos desafios
isso faz com que o óleo de os olhos de
empreendedores como eu pra ele porque o
empreendedor é movido pela dificuldade é
movido pelo desafio
então quando um quanto maior o desafio
maior oportunidade só que no caso do
governo existem tantas peculiaridade que
esse essa oportunidade vem acompanhada
de uma dificuldade também muito grande
quando você pensa em prender com o
governo e aí você a primeira coisa que
você faz você vai conversar com os
grandes gurus e especialistas da área
e aí o cara olha para você assim foi pai
por que você não faz tipo que você quer
fazer
só que sem envolver o governo aí você
fala meu amigo para aí se eu quero
transformar o governo de dentro para
fora como é que vou fazer um modelo de
negócio que envolva o governo
e foi com essa resposta que a gente
perdeu vários vários a oportunidade de
investimento na nossa empresa é então
empreender é traz muito suor muita
dificuldade e tem gente que tem
depressão
crise de ansiedade ea maioria dos jovens
que têm esse desejo de empreender esse
desejo de empreender movido pela
embriaguez das histórias de sucesso né é
glamour fama dinheiro as pessoas acham
que prendeu tipo james bond né
quando na verdade está mais para rambo
assim né está jogado na lama sozinho
levando tire tudo quanto é lado atirando
para tudo quanto é lado mesmo tempo e
tentando sobreviver
no nosso caso esse desafio ainda maior
porque a gente tinha de um lado pessoas
totalmente satisfeitos com a realidade
dos governos querem de fato é fazer tudo
por fora querendo transformar o que
estava acontecendo porque não acreditava
mais na itália e do outro lado você tem
algo pessoas do governo que não
representa a sociedade quando a missão
delas é representar e servir à sociedade
isso não fala só no brasil não isso fala
no mundo inteiro em 2012
a gente foi ao vale do silício pela
primeira vez que a gente tocou os
investidores lá e ficar aí chorando pra
cara da gente assim eu só faltei que só
faltou só ter sido expulso da sala para
criar uma cadeira na minha cabeça
sincero com você é louco crê fazer uma
startup voltada para o governo em 2013
os caras olhava se falava legal mas não
obrigado
em 2014 já começamos a ver um certo
interesse alierta oscar já começando a
se aproximar um pouco mais dessa
realidade em 2015
de repente todas as portas estavam
abertas a gente foi recebido pelos
maiores fundos de investimento vale do
silício conversas muito produtivas e que
foi que mudou nesses anos para pensar em
2011 quando começaram as manifestações
no mundo todo primavera árabe em 2013
manifestações no brasil ou seja foram
necessárias todo esse movimento no
brasil inteiro para o grande gênio do
vale do silício perceber uma coisa que
aqui já tinha percebido algum tempo até
que essa coisa as pessoas que querem e
podem e os governos devem e precisam
então primeiro vamos analisar como é que
a gente resolve esse problema temos aí o
impacto da tecnologia nisso tudo
a tecnologia faz com que as pessoas se
conectam mais uma comunicação mais
fluida e mais transparente
a gente começou a perceber que vinham
iniciativas querendo pressionar os
governos de fora pra dentro ou fazer
coisa independente do governo e do outro
lado pessoas que querem entrar no
governo para transformar de dentro pra
fora então foi nesse contexto de forças
externas e internas operando
simultaneamente que surgiu com o lábio e
o colar bicola de uma rede social para a
cidadania na qual as pessoas podem
fiscalizar problemas da cidade
ou seja publicar buracos nas vias
semáforos quebrados iluminação pública
irregular uma fiação que está solta na
calçada o entulho está atrapalhando a
passagem do pedestre
podem propor melhorias urbanas como uma
nova faixa de pedestre
uma rampa de acessibilidade uma nova
ciclofaixa e podem avaliar serviços e
espaços públicos dando nota mesmo para
as escolas para a rodoviária para o
ponto de ônibus no quesito de limpeza de
acessibilidade de infraestrutura etc
isso tudo de forma aberta ou seja todo
mundo pode ver tudo está acontecendo e
de forma transparente também fazendo com
que toda essa comunicação fica
disponível para que os governos saibam
que as pessoas querem e as pessoas vejam
tudo bem que o governo está fazendo
então o colóquio deu essa e se essa
quantidade certa de cidadania na mão das
pessoas então seja através do site ou
através do aplicativo
as pessoas podem fazer essas publicações
e fica ali na rede social onde as outras
pessoas podem apoiar podem comentar
pode acompanhar o que está acontecendo e
conseguem é participar de fato consegue
aprender com a visão do outro o que
acontece na cidade de errado e como é
que antes eu achava que não era errado e
que agora eu consigo enxergar
do lado do governo a gente oferece uma
plataforma de gestão
essa aqui é o nosso grande esse berg que
tem por trás do do aplicativo
a gente oferece uma ferramenta para que
todas as publicações que chegam na rede
social chega na mão dos governos
eles conseguem caminhar pelas pessoas
responsáveis de cada secretaria
acompanhar todo o fluxo de atendimento
de resolução de cada tipo de problema
isso gerando todos os tipos de estado
busca de informação e inteligência para
que os governos todos se tornem mais
eficientes e mais inteligente e dando
essa visão diferente diferença da cidade
então a gente ouve muito prefeito assim
nossa nunca vi uma cidade desse jeito
ele olha esse mapa com os pontos lá com
cascata com todas as categorias e o
status de cada tipo de publicação e
consegue entender o que está acontecendo
na cidade de maneira que ele nunca
conseguiria entender antes de uma vez
que a gente que a gente lançou sua
plataforma para o governo a gente desse
primeiro passo é que foi o dia olhando
pensar política o ciclo das políticas
públicas
a gente tem o seu primeiro forma agenda
e fórmulas políticas
depois você passa pelo processo de
tomada de decisão ou seja que políticas
eu vou implementar e por fim você vai
implementar as políticas e faz essa
avaliação e aí pra gente começou a gente
começou pelo fim de tudo a gente
permitir que as pessoas passassem a
avaliar a implementação das políticas
aqui muito mais voltado para a parte de
ad zeladoria de prestação dos serviços
mas a gente começou por aqui e aí a
gente começa a ver o que foi que
aconteceu né isso pra grande surpresa da
gente
em três anos a gente atingiu 100
prefeituras que usa nossa plataforma
enquanto no começo lá atrás que a gente
criou a gente achava que seria
necessário uma uma massa de pessoas
milhares de pessoas faziam centenas de
publicações para que os governos se
sentem pressionados e aderência
plataforma hoje a gente vê que isso
acontece
existem prefeituras que não tem uma
grande massa de gente já usando e ela se
torna esse incentivador da cidadania e
da participação das pessoas na cidade
então hoje a gente tem 150 mil pessoas
que usam essa plataforma e aí você vê
casos como teresina
no começo terezinha sua taxa de
atendimento de 30 por cento tais
publicações que eram feitas no cohab e
com todo esse trabalho que a gente vai
fazendo na nossa equipe junto com a
equipe da prefeitura super engajado em
fazer o negócio acontecer e mudar essa
realidade do atendimento hoje a
prefeitura de teresina a taxa de
resolução dos problemas na faixa de 70
por cento
qualquer cidadão de teresina que hoje
publica um problema e sempre duas horas
já recebe o primeiro atendimento
no caso de bauru também a prefeitura de
bauru é parceiro do colab e dá
atendimento praticamente 100% das
publicações que são feitas lá no caso de
niterói
o nível de precisão é tão grande que o
cidadão recebe a mensagem dizendo ah o
dia ea hora que aquela aquele serviço a
ser prestado então sim às 11 horas da
manhã da quinta feira vai passar o o
caminhão lá que vai recolher o entulho
na calçada atrapalhando neste nível de
precisão a comunicação acontece
e aí com essa esse modelo de plataforma
só olhando precisar pensar nesse lado de
fazer os governos escutarem é porque
quando você tem um problema de
credibilidade
você precisa fazer primeiro o que o
governo escute né pra ganhar com ele de
volta comece a agir
a gente foi eleito o melhor aplicativo
de cidades do mundo a gente foi eleito
uma das cinco soluções de governo mauri
participação pela onu prevê que a gente
participou em abu dhabi e mostra a gente
foi eleita em a startup de mãe pac
social de maior potência potencial de
globalização pelo bid e aí uma vez que a
gente fez nesse primeiro movimento a
gente foi para o próximo passo que é
trazer pessoas pra participarem do
processo de tomada de decisão então é
assim você começa o nível de
participação muito maior então você
antes tinha as pessoas participando na
fiscalizando e propondo e você já criou
esse ciclo de que as pessoas publicam a
prefeitura vai lá e resolve a tem
credibilidade porque parar pra pensar
imagina se você é da prefeitura é e você
chama as pessoas para participar do
processo de tomada de decisão
só que na roda na tua rua tá cheio de
buraco tem muito difícil pela calçada
tão gostoso esculhambado ea pessoa a
prefeitura de chão para criar um parque
no teu bairro assim para aí pouco na
sacanagem né
a minha rua que todos que trabalham no
país um serviço básico agora quer que eu
participo de um processo de de cocriação
não funciona você primeiro precisa
ganhar credibilidade das pessoas de
volta pra isso aquela participa da
tomada de decisão e aí a gente começou
em campinas por exemplo campinas o
primeiro passo a gente deu a gente fez
uma consulta através da nossa plataforma
para que as pessoas escolhessem o ritmo
ea banda de um evento cultural na cidade
e ganhou cpm 22 no rock com cpm 22
mas pequeno é uma decisão pequena mas o
que isso representa antes essa decisão
seria tomada dentro da secretaria de
cultura agora as pessoas participaram
daquela tomada de decisão e aí com
sucesso disso a gente fez o do próximo
passo que a gente fez uma consulta onde
a prefeitura investiu um milhão de reais
em um dos cinco projetos que a população
tinha que escolher uma sala de cinema
uma sala de artes uma oficina de corte e
costura um cinema ou o campo de futebol
soçaite e as pessoas foram voltando a
secretaria se envolver naquilo tentar
engajar a população para que o projeto
dela fosse o projeto vencedor e ganhou
oficina de corte costura e hoje está
gerando já é resultado para milhares de
pessoas na cidade de campinas
a gente fez parte disso a gente
participou desse processo de
desintermediação é trazer as pessoas
para participar diretamente de uma
decisão que antes seja tomada somente
dentro da prefeitura em santos a gente
deu um passo além e agora a gente tá
fazendo orçamento o orçamento
participativo de forma digital na nossa
plataforma
então é as pessoas colocam bairro e
dentro do bairro mas podem escolher
vários projetos na área de educação e
saúde de cultura e esporte de
assistência social e dos serviços
públicos ea está sendo muito emocionante
porque não assino só através do
aplicativo na internet
a prefeitura junto com a gente está indo
nas comunidades onde tem muitos idosos
onde existem pessoas que não têm acesso
à internet com o que ele montou um
quiosque para que as pessoas que nunca
para teriam essa participação possam dar
suas opiniões a respeito dos projetos
que o impacto da comunidade dela nas
escolas também essa mesma iniciativa
está fácil trazer os estudantes para
participar basta uma decisão trazendo
estudante para pra fazer parte do
orçamento participativo
vocês conseguem enxergar o poder de
transformação disso e todo esse desafio
da gente até então foram muito dentro do
governo foram desafios que a gente
precisou provar o quanto seria benéfico
para com a prefeitura tem uma relação um
relacionamento mais aberto
deus e mais transparente com a população
como ela poderia gerar mais eficiência
economizar recurso público a prestar
melhores serviços sem ter mais
representatividade para o momento que
ela toma decisões junto
essas pessoas ou seja um desafio interno
mas o que é que o futuro guarda né
quando você olha para o futuro e aí você
olha no psycho das políticas públicas
você precisa fazer a forma a fazer
formação de agenda a formulação das
políticas
isso não dá pra fazer só o colapso junto
com o governo não dá a relação entre a
sociedade e os governos que ia ser muito
mais simbiótica aqui e foi por isso que
a gente criou recentemente o primeiro
programa de transformadores colab o que
a gente fez
a gente chamou 31 jovens de 16 cidades
brasileiras entre 18 e 30 anos foram
mais de 650 inscritos a gente selecionou
esses jovens e trouxe jorge para são
paulo
pessoas como mário por exemplo se é da
periferia de recife
sempre morei comunidade e estava
tentando descobrir um pouco desse papel
dele de como ele vai trazer de volta os
benefícios à comunidade dele como é que
tudo que aprendeu na vida ele vai trazer
de volta
então hoje mário já participa de
iniciativas que levam cultura arte e
tecnologia pra comunidade para preferir
do de recife como as pessoas com uma
taxa única de salvador é muito envolvida
com o empreendedorismo com a difusão de
hortas domiciliares e salvador com um
projeto super legal
então a gente trouxe as pessoas e no
primeiro dia delas em são paulo junto
com as outras 29 pessoas
a gente deu um olhar sobre a sociedade
a gente levou essas pessoas para
conhecer a realidade da periferia de
ocupações no centro da cidade são paulo
e aí a gente a gente for enfrentar a
realidade por exemplo a gente foi no
grajaú que o gato dentro de são paulo
você pegar uma balsa para chegar lá e
como é que essas pessoas vivem e de
repente a gente tava sentado com essas
pessoas da periferia que tem tudo pra
dar errado na vida e estava conseguindo
executar com estavam conseguindo fazer
coisas acontecerem repente a gente se
viu lá sentado nessa roda com essas
pessoas da periferia dando aula pra
gente dando a um banho de conhecimento
um banho de atitude
no final do primeiro dia estava todo
mundo assim já completamente destruído
transformados abit por tudo que você
acredita
já tinha vindo a
no segundo dia as levou as pessoas para
dentro do governo levando o poder da
prefeitura de campinas
melhor para a prefeitura de são paulo
fez com que essas pessoas conhecessem a
realidade de quem está dentro do governo
tentando fazer acontecer e que também
sofre preconceito porque aqui no brasil
dentro do governo é tudo ladrão e no
terceiro dia essas pessoas se sentarão
juntas e co criar um parte das soluções
que vão mudar o mundo e que vão
continuar transformando o nosso futuro
porque eu o que a gente vive hoje é o
presente e um futuro que um dia foi
provável
então é preciso a gente continuar
acreditando é preciso continuar se
negando a acreditar apenas nos futuros
prováveis isso isso é muito um papel do
empreendedor
então se você foi parar pra pensar quem
está vivendo no país hoje somos nós
são vocês vocês precisam parar de
acreditar pelo futuro provável de
continuar buscando essas esses futuros
prováveis e aí eu pergunto qual é o
futuro provável que você vai sinaga
acreditar qual é o futuro provável que
você não vai buscar qual é o futuro
provável que você vai ajudar a construir
muito obrigado